the horseshoe crap it's a living fossil
that has called earth it's home for
almost half a billion years its outlived
dinosaurs and survived mass extinctions
and ice ages but today it's facing a new
threat their adaptations have worked
with the way the earth has changed and
slowly in recent years with the with
humans
bringing impacts to their population
that they've started to have defines
rising sea levels habitat loss and over
harvesting all threatened the population
but if you've ever had a vaccine
injection or a medical implant then you
might not know that you've been relying
on this prehistoric creatures blood to
save your life now after decades of
waiting a new synthetic solution could
change over here on our beaches on the
Delaware Bay it is a place that people
are witnessing a phenomena that they
cannot see anywhere else it's the
equivalent of the wildebeest crossing
the Serengeti in May and June here on
the Delaware Bay where we are right now
millions of crabs come out on a high
tide lay their eggs about six inches
deep in the sand and they will stay in
the sand and hatch in about a month and
horseshoe crab eggs are a really
critical part of the ecosystem here if a
single crab is laying almost a hundred
thousand eggs that is providing a food
source for shorebirds
for gulls for fish for Terrapins
and then all up the food chain for that
and then what happens with the horseshoe
crabs then trickles down to the whole
ecosystem here they just have managed to
evolve with the changing oceans and the
changing land
the reason this crab has been able to
evolve for so long it's blue blood
this copper-based blood contains special
cells called amoeba sites which are
extremely sensitive to endow top
these are contaminants released from the
cell walls of harmful bacteria and they
can cause life-threatening fever or
toxic shock as soon as the amoeba sites
detect any of these endotoxins the blood
clots around the intruder in mobilizing
it and protecting the crab from
infection in the 1960s scientists found
a way to harness this unique super power
to make sure our medical supplies were
free from contamination and it replaced
slower more unpredictable tests
involving rabbits the formula is called
Limulus amoeba site lycée or Lal and
relies on amoeba sites taken from
horseshoe crab blood and so every year
half-a-million crabs are collected along
the Atlantic coast as well as across the
eastern shores of Mexico and China a
third of the crabs blood is drawn before
their release back into the ocean it's
estimated that 15 percent of crabs
collected died as a result of this
bleeding process which could mean the
loss of 75 thousand crabs in the US
every year
an alternative was found however almost
20 years ago here in Singapore
in the past say 20 30 years ago we
managed to collect 30 pieces in one
afternoon but now it is difficult to
find a even a few in the mid-1980s
professor Dean Jack Lang needed lal for
work involving IVF embryos but there was
a problem
Singapore research was not very well
funded so because then Ali L was so
expensive we had to find a good way to
understand how the Herschel crab blood
works so my research collaborator also
my husband together with our research
students went to the kranji mud flats to
look for her shoe crabs and to bring a
few samples back to the way
we clean them we tag them and we took
only a small volume of the blood
isolating the blood cells from the
hostile crap and we could produce our
own equivalent of Lal this synthetic
equivalent is called recombinant factor
C and it's a clone of the main gene in a
horseshoe crabs blood which is sensitive
to bacterial endotoxins it was a moment
of realization that it's going to change
the biomedical industry and it's going
to save a very very highly threatened
species but pharmaceutical companies
didn't come around as quickly as
professor ding had hoped and so years
and then decades past were a highly
regulated industry and to say we would
like to market a new medicine a lot of
people are reluctant to take a chance on
trying something new that's until a
scientist at pharmaceutical company Eli
Lilly with a particular hobby came along
birding is a hobby of mine so to go to
Delaware Bay and see the horseshoe crab
spawning it kind of put it all together
for me so the the horseshoe crab is a
keystone species in its ecology
obviously for its own sake but then for
a lot of other animals that depend on it
if we use our FC then then there are any
crabs that are affected whether it's
mortality or whether there's some
behavioural affect by taking by taking
the blood studies have shown that the
RFC test is a more effective and a
potentially cheaper solution than Lal
changing Minds however remain the
biggest challenge there's been several
times I I was I was ready to throw in
the towel so it's been it's been a
difficult journey to fight internally to
fight externally nobody likes change but
we think we're doing it for the right
reasons we have had success and we do if
we have the data at the end of the day
persistence paid off and in 2018 the
first drug to use the recombinant factor
C test was approved by the FDA and Eli
Lilly is planning to transition 90% of
its tests to the synthetic by the end of
2020
I think the consequence if industry
carries on with bleeding crabs is at
some point there won't be any so there
are real impacts to what we're doing and
the longer we say oh you know they'll be
available forever it's it's likely not
true it is important that we as humans
are playing a role in protecting
biodiversity and not impacting
biodiversity the synthetic version of
the horseshoe crab lie say it used by
pharmaceutical industry is going to have
a major impact on horseshoe crab
conservation it's not the only factor
that we need we also need to continue
with harvest limits and with beach
restoration but reducing the need to
harvest crabs for the use of their blood
will have a major impact
[Music]